Speaker 1: A better O'Rourke confronted the
Texas Republican governor and lieutenant
governor yesterday at a press conference
about the Uvalde, Texas, shooting, and Beto
was marched out by police officers. Okay. There
are some who are saying this was a despicable
grandstanding attempt. I completely disagree.
A better job is actually showing passion and
concern for what's going on. Beto is not blaming
doors like Republicans and cliques increasingly
are. Let's look at the confrontation. You will
hear that as governor of Texas, Greg Abbott,
who said mental illness is the only problem here.
Greg Abbott tries to turn it over to Dan Patrick,
the lieutenant governor, and then Beto
interrupts. And then they start insulting Beto
and telling him he's embarrassing or whatever.
And then Beto is ultimately removed by police.
Speaker 3: This time, I will pass the
mic to Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick.
Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me.
Speaker 4: Sir. Sit down. You're out.
You're out of line in an embarrassing answer.
Speaker 1: So if you're listening, Beto is now
been approached by police. That is right now.
Speaker 4: And you are doing nothing. No,
please. To get his ass out of you.
This in the place you talk to.
Speaker 3: So this is totally predictable. When
he serves, you're out of line. Sure you are.
Speaker 1: They do not like being
confronted, do they? And you see Ted
Cruz like a statue on the stage. And I'm sure.
Speaker 4: You're out of line. Please leave his
sartorial connections out. Yeah. I can't believe
you're sick. Son of a bitch. You would come to a
deal like this to make a political issue.
Speaker 1: He's called the sick son of a
bitch for making this a political issue.
When is the right time to. To talk about
the politics of what's going on? Because it's
a political issue for a Republican governor
and a Republican lieutenant governor
who are willing to consider any solution
to the gun violence problem as long as
it doesn't involve dealing with the guns.
That's politics. And this idea of, oh,
you're injecting politics. Give me a break.
And there is video marched out of there by
police. Oh, Betto was rude. Let's denounce
him for his tone. He didn't wait his turn to
speak. He didn't wait enough days before. It's
okay to talk about politics. Betto is saying what
anyone with common sense has been thinking and
saying for a really long time. And they are doing
politics by packing the stage with Republicans.
They're doing politics by excluding dealing
with gun safety as a solution. Blame doors,
rap music. I'm going to play a clip
later of them blaming rap music.
And yet shame on Betto. And Betto, after getting
kicked out, he kept going outside. This is
another viral video with more than 2 million.
Speaker 3: Views in the nation and mental health
care access. 50th. There are only 50 states in
the nation. We are dead. Last, the number one
provider of mental health care services under
Greg Abbott in the state of Texas is the county
jail system. In the state of Texas. The largest
inpatient mental health care facility in the state
of Texas is the Harris County Jail. All right.
Speaker 1: So you get the picture and listen,
Betto, Betto did nothing wrong when when
nobody else is willing to do anything that
connects to the actual issue. At least he's
out there trying to get some attention. Let
me know your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. We'll take a quick break and be right back